what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a video called
f modern day women before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
all right [ __ ] modern day women this
that was harsh harsh
does that mean any woman born today
probably not a new
generation of modern day women are
psychopathic
they're masculine they're narcissistic
they're entitled and essentially
they're spoiled little brats they want
everything
and they expect to give nothing else in
return but their vagina
well i've got news for you my dear your
vagina
isn't special you thought by making the
song whap
where else [ __ ] that you were
celebrating your femininity
you weren't what you were essentially
doing
is telling us what we already knew
you're a hoe don't be offended
that was the hook of the song there's
some holes
in this house there's some holes in this
house
there's some holes in this house
and this new generation of women shook
their bbls
in celebration now dave chappelle once
said that if [ __ ] was a stock can i be
honest guys for one
second sorry for one second could i be
honest
when i was growing up oh my gosh i don't
i don't know if i should say this i'm
not i'm not trying to flex
okay but i usually had like
the biggest like butt out of my friends
and baby owls have really
like now it's like my butt isn't even
big anymore
honestly i'm sorry this
i don't i don't even know if i'm gonna
post this part because this is so out of
pocket but
it just makes me mad it makes me mad
because
i have it naturally and yeah now my butt
looks small now it looks small
why because you flooded the market with
your [ __ ]
i can now download an app and in half an
hour
i can have sex with at least 50 women
within a two mile radius if i want to
your [ __ ] is no longer special
and now we get to the modern day man a
desperate shameless embarrassing little
simp
who will do or say anything to get
inside the vagina
of this modern day woman he will
literally sell
his assets just to be in her good books
this man will put himself in debt
trying to please her every outlandish
entitled behavior
and she knows it and she'll play on it
and she will manipulate it and she will
mold him into the effeminate
little boy she desires as long as her
needs are being fulfilled
the roles are being reversed men
are becoming women and women
are becoming men yeah i would agree with
that on some level
like i think men are definitely becoming
more feminine and women are becoming
more masculine
women are killing the very spirit of men
every day and men are becoming more and
more
desperate for this narcissistic
psychopaths attention
not me and well yeah because he probably
has
options eighty percent of men don't have
options so if this modern day woman
feels aggrieved by a man she will stand
in his face
shoulders back chest out and attempt to
have a fight with him
as if she's a man and a lot of the time
i don't know why girls do that
she does and men knowing
that there is a system that is so
heavily skewed towards women
will have to hang their heads and back
down from this
narcissistic little psychopath and even
if he raises his
voice at her he will be automatically
seen
as the aggressor because men obviously
are more physically stronger than women
women are becoming more masculine and
men are becoming more feminine
and she knows it and she will cry and
she will play victim
knowing that her behavior is championed
by a system
that seeks to break the very spirit of
men yeah i agree with that some women
really take advantage of men
and they treat them like objects [ __ ]
modern day women
they know how to shop they know how to
buy wigs
they know how to do that yeah oh my gosh
women today do
not know how to save money i swear to
god
and they always gosh they invest money
in the wrong things
makeup but do they know how to boil rice
do they know how to raise children hey
i feel attacked
i'm sorry rice is like the one thing
that i can't cook i buy the packets
because i've given up
look it it's harder than it looks i
swear to god
[ __ ] modern day women they seem to want
chivalry
from the 1920s while they act like a
spoiled little child
they will tell you i want a man who's
six foot two i want a man who makes six
figures
i want a man who is loyal i want a man
who is ex i want a man who is why
i want a man to give me the world and
wrap it in a bowl
no it doesn't go like that i have no
doubt
that modern-day women will see this
message and revert to their normal
insults when called out on their
behavior they will say oh he's broke
oh he's gay oh he can't handle the
strong woman
not really now some of the stuff he's
saying is true
some women are wretched some guys are
wretched people
people when left of their own devices
don't tend to do the right thing
just in general what does jordan
peterson say he says like
when you look back at history look at
yourself as the oppressor
that's what i think with human nature
when you take away the consequences
people don't tend to do the right thing
and with women they've taken away a lot
of the consequences and for a lot of
the behavior like look at cardi b what
consequences has she really faced
i mean yeah okay her man cheats on her
right but
so does beyonce who carries herself in a
completely different way
and cardi still has a ring she still has
two kids with the same guy
she still makes a ton of money great
career
where was the consequence none of the
above is true
men are just tired of your [ __ ]
we love you but this right here
is tough love what do you bring
by headaches narcissism
and entitled behavior are women gonna
like hearing this
no do i care
no somebody had to say it right
somebody do you know how many people say
this in the nanosphere that is not
new news um yeah as i said you take away
the consequences people tend to act a
certain way
um so i don't necessarily disagree with
what he's saying um
guys don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and please follow my instagram
okay it's just pearly things with a z
the link is in the description you just
click it in the description we'll go to
my instagram you can follow it
i'm trying to hit 10 000 subs oh wait
followers on instagram
that would be cool yeah and um also ring
the notification bell the way you're
gonna be notified for my daily videos
i'm gonna talk to you guys
next time
oh wait it didn't stop